welcome back to previous organizers
celebrities are denouncing veganism on
mass the market for plant-based rules
falling off a cliff it was increasingly
likely that the rest of the world agrees
with me which is often what happens with
issues Infamous activist Tash Peterson
better known as vegan booty he's on a
mission to change people's minds by all
means necessary so his veganism here to
stay or As Dead As a stake on my plate
later this evening I'm joined by vegan
booty Tash Peterson and I'll kick host
and fox commentator Tommy Lauren all
right
would you go by the name vegan or began
it's Miss Booty or what Tash Peterson is
fine yes veganism is going out of
fashion meatless Farm announcer only
production beyond meat shares crashed 95
most vegan companies in this country
lack of consumer demands now I think
people have got fed up with it I think
one of the reasons is they're Fed Up
would be shouted at you you're one of
these people that runs into restaurants
and plays you know sounds from screaming
animals and other trials and so on I
know you get passionately about it I
think it's very off-putting it's a bit
like the just stop oil protesters doing
a lot of their stuff it just annoys
people has the opposite effect to what
you hope no I don't think so at all I
think it brings more attention to the
animal Holocaust animals are subjected
to rape torture enslavement abuse and
murder and I'm bringing light to that
and I'm seeing why would you use the
words why use the word holocaust
Holocaust is the mass extermination of
more than six million Jewish people by
Adolf Hitler Nazis one Holocaust in
history why would you why would you have
people know that as the Holocaust why
would you use that kind of very emotive
language knowing it would offend a lot
of people well it's just a factual
statement if you look at the definition
of a holocaust it is Slaughter or
destruction on a mass scale multiple
holocausts have occurred throughout
human history and non-human animals can
be subjected to the same atrocities that
humans can in fact it's the largest
Holocaust in history with three trillion
individuals brutally murdered every year
for human food consumption all right
Tommy you're from a ranching family I
don't know about you I just find I don't
mind people being vegans you don't want
to eat meat it's absolutely fine I get
some of the reasons why they don't want
to personal choice you know they care
about animals and so on although I would
point out animals eat a lot of animals
just for the record naturally
um what do you feel about this whole
vegan debate are we getting bored with
it it seems to me from all the sales in
the UK and stuff it's kind of going out
of fashion like it was a fad for a lot
of people they've gone back to munching
meat
well veganism is an effort so I must be
Tommy sorry
yeah I think a lot of people realize
that it wasn't in fact the healthier
choice because when they choose this
beyond meat or these other substitutes
it's actually just packed with different
fillers so it's not actually this
cleaner option like a lot of people
thought at the onset of the whole vegan
craze but I gotta tell you speaking of
the animal Holocaust which I think is a
ridiculous thing to say I'm from a
ranching family I'm from a ranching
State there's nobody that cares more for
their animals than those in the ranching
and farming communities now I'm against
Factory ranching and farming as well by
the way I think that that's atrocious
I'm an animal lover but as somebody who
comes from a ranching family I can tell
you that ranchers and Farmers care for
their livestock dearly yes it does at
the end of the day turn into a product
for human consumption but that doesn't
mean that it is always inhumane that
it's always discussing that it's this
animal Holocaust or genocide as your
guest was referring to it as it's also
really annoying to me when people try to
say that animals are causing climate
change I mean if you don't want to eat
animals because you love animals or you
have a health reason that prevents you
from eating animals that's fine but this
whole environmental craze that we need
to get rid of animals because they're
causing climate change that's also a
step too far and part of the reason why
this whole vegan craze is going out the
window yeah and being a Bear Grylls said
recently I was a vegan quite a few years
uh he said but I thought it was good for
the environment I thought it was good
for my health and through time and
experience and knowledge and study I
realized I was wrong on both counts it
was bad for the environment bad for
itself he was never a vegan in the first
place because he's an ethical view again
murder if you're against animal abuse
and murder you never contribute it to it
again he wrote a vegan cookbook it
wasn't actually a vegan cookbook it
contained animal abuse you're saying bad
girls was a fake vegan he never was a
vegan he was a vegan no yeah he's alive
he's not a lie huh no well I've looked
at the cookbook you may not have no more
products you may not have liked the fact
that he went back to eating meat but he
was a vegan for quite a while
that label all the time but if they
actually truly hold their ethical view
against animal abuse and murder then
they would never turn back on veganism
you know Tommy over here I railed
against a vegan sausage rolls I didn't
like the way they appropriated the
language of meat products I don't think
vegan companies should be allowed to use
words like sausage rolls or steaks
because that's meat
yeah exactly and they're filled with soy
and fillers and other disgusting things
that you actually don't want to put into
your body and meat tastes good that's
why all of these fake meat companies try
to make it taste like meat it never
actually comes to fruition because it
still tastes like crap and I would also
point out during covid when we were
having shortages in the grocery store if
you looked for meat it was sometimes
hard to find at least here in the U.S
but that beyond meat crap that was
always available because people don't
want it the consumers are deciding that
they want maybe an organic option maybe
a free range option but people still
want to eat meat and you can eat meat
and respect animals at the same time it
can be done it's been done since the
dawn of time but we are beyond beyond
meat now we're going back to munching
meat I love meat I won't be spread
otherwise not that there are better
tactics to running into restaurants and
playing noises of screaming animals
personally thank you for coming on the
program uh Tasha and thank you to Tommy
as always